do you ever look at cake decorating and
Instagram and thank God I could never do
that well guess what yes you can buy a
professionally decorated cake and cost
hundreds of dollars doesn't take that
much extra effort or talent to decorate
your own cake at home we're going to
teach you five really easy decorating
styles to judge up your next cake
honestly like cake it's like a really
tangible way to show people that you
love them first things first we have to
prep our cakes to be decorated put a
little icing secure the board on top of
that and start building our cakes all
you're willing to do is plop a good
amount of icing down first more than you
think honestly you don't have to worry
about it being perfect you could pipe it
on if you wanted but I don't know it's
not really like the biggest deal in the
world and then for the top layer you're
actually gonna put it bottom side down
that's a lot flatter we want a really
sharp edge to our cake you might have to
move it a little bit to make sure that
it's totally level on all sides and then
put a whole bunch of frosting on top I
like to take the back of my spatula and
just dab the icing onto the cake and
then you're gonna use the offset spatula
to flatten out the sides and get off any
excess icing this is your primer if you
will on your cake to ensure that the
finished coat is going to go on really
nice and smooth as you can see there's
crumbs that kind of get caught in the
mess and that's why it's called a crumb
coat we're gonna chill that until we're
ready to decorate to make this job
really easy all you need is a piping bag
a spoon and offset spatula you know I
love them a cake board and a rotating
cake stand if possible lastly you'll
need a rosette piping tip not all of
these tools are necessary I mean really
all you need is a piping bag and the tip
but they make the job a lot easier first
things first we're gonna put the piping
tip into the back then turn it right
around and put the bag over your
non-dominant hand with the top of the
bag kind of fold it down you're gonna
use your thumb actually to help scrape
off the extra icing put the top back up
and squeeze it in between your thumb and
your hand and that's where you're gonna
have all the pressure coming out of so a
lot of people want to press down kind of
in the middle of a bag and it actually
gives a lot of uneven pressure and
that's not what you want to do it's
actually a lot harder as well so when
you're making a rosette you start in the
middle apply even pressure until the end
and just curve around
really
easy and then at the very end when
you're trying to make the edge of your
rosette you just flip your wrist a
little bit wrap it around and release
that pressure you just kind of quickly
dismount dismount that's a good word for
it yeah he just smashed the first view
that you do they're gonna feel kind of
awkward you're gonna have some that look
better than others but I will say just
go for it to fill in those holes that
are naturally going to be there all you
need to do is just put the tip down in
that hole
apply a little bit of pressure and then
kind of flick your wrist so it almost
looks like it's kind of part of a petal
of a nearby rosette the reason why the
rosette cake is great is you really
don't have to be perfect
it looks so cool when it's done it's so
elegant it's really really easy it's
just one piping tip of one icing color
next thing you know it looks like you've
been doing this for years so to start
the ombre cake you're going to take the
darkest color and pipe it around the
bottom put two thick layers of icing on
the bottom and then do two stripes of
the next color just choose whatever
colors you want you could do from like a
dark blue all the way to a really really
light blue we were going for more of a
sunrise look like a tequila sunrises
what we're calling this cake I'm gonna
top it with white so it's gonna be a
really nice gradient of colors this tool
is a bench scraper or a dough cutter you
can drag it right along the bottom of
the stand itself so it'll be really
really level if you want to really clean
stripe you can start here but we were
going that greedy and ombre look so then
you're going to use that excess frosting
and go up go down go in a few different
directions so that you're really getting
a good mix of all of the colors together
the fun thing about this is honestly
like anyone can do it it's so easy and
you really just have to know when to
stop like that's usually my problem is I
just want to go and go and I just have
more fun with it
we're just topping with a little bit of
crushed graham cracker and an umbrella
because we can just play with it that's
the fun thing about decorating cakes is
they can be kind of kitschy or elegant
or whatever really you want them to be I
think we really just need a vacation
that might be why we went with the
sunset we're gonna show you how to make
homemade buttercream succulents and for
dyeing your frosting we recommend using
gel colors or just a little bit more
saturated we're going for kind of a dark
greenish gray kind of color I'm using
some green a little bit of brown and a
little bit of blue a little goes a long
way so start with a little you can
always add more all right so I've got
the green I'm also gonna use a little
bit of pink for these succulents and so
this is I don't know what tip is this oh
yeah it's a petal nozzle yep that's it
this one's great for making roses and
succulents what we're gonna do is put a
stripe of pink down one side of the bag
and similar to the ombre cake but it
doesn't have to be perfect just get it
in there from right to the start of the
piping tip all the way to the top of the
bag then we're gonna fill in the rest
with the green color and again I'm going
to use my thumb here to scrape off the
icing when it gets into the bag we're
gonna twist make sure there's no air
bubbles and set that aside while you
grab some parchment paper so just a
little square is what we're gonna use to
make our succulents on and you're going
to just test the icing to make sure that
the color is coming out the way that you
want it to kind of shmoop shmoop get it
out there until I'm happy with the color
new piece of parchment and I'm gonna
make a mound of icing in the middle and
then do an X shape over that and then
you're going to do little C shapes all
around that excuse me
to a quarter-turn in between each one
when you're trying to dismount that
icing I think it's better to go down
into the parchment itself and then just
keep going until you're happy with the
size of that succulent at the same
nozzle you can play with it and create
different shapes you're gonna turn the
bag to ensure that the pink size kind of
on the top of the nozzle when it's
coming out and you're gonna go to kind
of a loop motion turning your parchment
around and going these little loop some
chilly you're like all the way around
and just keep going up until you have a
beautiful unique little cactus like this
please buy a beginner's piping set all
of the tips that we used here are like
kind of the standard wanted to come in
there you're nervous about spending a
bunch of money on frosting but you still
want to practice your piping you
culinary school they used to have us buy
powdered instant mashed potatoes and
practice with that top tip you heard of
here first
don't take it too seriously just have
fun and then while those are chilling in
the fridge we're going to assemble our
naked cake so this one's really cool and
looks really elegant and it's
ridiculously easy to do similar to a
crumb coat you're gonna take a bench
scraper and scrape off all the excess
you're gonna really push into the cake
and get as much icing off as you can so
it's gonna look you know make it a very
trendy right now they're very in and
then you can start putting on your
seconds these came straight out of the
freezer so that they're really easy to
work with
it looks very intimidating in the you
ain't I want to try it because you think
that like people will think that your
piping is not good but the point of this
and why it's so great is that there's so
much on there and it's just like an
overwhelming beautiful gorgeous unique
cake that you don't see everywhere and
you should just go ahead and try it now
for the drip cake very dramatic and
elegant and also very on-trend you make
a really simple white chocolate ganache
and then died at this really gorgeous
beholder
you pour the ganache kind of in fourths
along the cake so the cakes really cold
the ganache is warm and by pouring the
warm ganache under the cold cake it's
gonna kind of set as it goes missiny is
a dinner spoon and kind of coax the
ganache in the direction that I want to
make sure that it's pulling down the
side of
you could use a piping bag or a little
squeeze bottle to do this so we thought
this is like a really organic natural
way as well as not really needing a ton
of lecture equipment you could top it
with anything candy like runs or just
leave a plane it looks really gorgeous
the clean shiny top as well
[Music]
Mira glaze is an absolute showstopper do
not be intimidated you can do this you
just have to be prepared so make sure
that you have all your knees and PLAs
ready as you do have to work quickly
with this glaze to make sure that it's
really really well mixed we recommend
using a stick blender if you put cling
film on the top that can help get rid of
any extra bubbles but as you can see
some are may just want to get out as
many as you can
the ideal temperature to pour the mirror
glaze on top of the cake is anywhere
between 90 to 96 degrees Fahrenheit the
most important things about doing a
mirror glaze is one making sure that
it's frozen solid and to making sure
that it's as smooth as you can possibly
get it the glaze is warm when you're
pouring it on so the cold cake will help
the place that really nicely on the cake
[Music]
take an offset spatula and do a little
shoot and it really completes that
marble look this is a fun part it's when
all of the hard work pays off and you
just watch this mesmerizing process take
shape
because we just can't help ourselves we
had to add a little bit of silver leaf
to the top as well most of it will drip
off you just want to make sure that
you're getting a good mix of the two
colors
blue oh my god
[Music]
every occasion every party has cake and
this is just a few helpful tips to help
you make yours really stand out at your
next event so all the care all the
effort all the fun creativity that goes
into making these cakes don't be afraid
to eat them in the end that's the whole
point of that they're like something
great to look at but also something
great to eat and enjoy with your loved
ones really though what are all those
damn tips called
oh no but like all the different styles
like I don't know the one that makes the
squiggly bit I don't know like whatever
just by like the mixed like five of them
I don't know
[Music]
you